[Music]
foreign
guys sorry about that
about a mic check mic check mic check
Mike is checked okay all right so we're
skip forget the countdown numbers you
guys see
forget the countdown
uh because
my computer decided to just totally
forget everything so
we're gonna go ahead and do this right
here
here ladies and gentlemen
all right let me try to uh we're gonna
have to do
this little guy right here
and I'll explain to you guys
what happened right there
see I want to fit this to the screen
how's everybody doing tonight
L when getting things started
with the 20 gifted yeah alerts are gonna
I'm surprised they're working at all the
alerts
oh and thank you so much for the gifted
guys everybody who just got one of the
gifted memberships right there
make sure you thank Elwyn in the chat
uh this has been a long time coming guys
a long time coming so I should have
known that
my OBS would just totally decide to mess
up tonight
you know how those updates are right and
people always tell you don't do the
update
until you read everything so I didn't
read everything and
ah yeah so I couldn't what happened was
I was able to pull up the game and
everything but I couldn't hear the audio
I couldn't hear any audio of the game
so I'm thinking okay I've messed
something up
try it completely got rid of it added it
again
and it didn't it it just it just didn't
respond didn't respond
so then I open up uh stream elements
or not stream elements what is this
called streamlabs obs
and that one's like oh sure here's your
audio right right in your in your
glorious ears it sounds fine
the Glorious audio I mean glorious ears
listen to me dude
Mrs raconteur got a gifted
from Elwyn oh that's so funny
Mrs raikintura congratulations on your
gift membership there make sure now you
can spam the emotes there in the chat
you also get discount on merch if you
were at all interested
and you get a special role in the
Discord I don't even think my wife knows
what a Discord is guys but it's all good
it's all good she provides a nice like
groundedness away from like the gaming
space you know if I need to just get
away and like not think about this kind
of stuff
oh man but guys sorry yeah I did not
mean to be late that was not intended I
uh was actually sitting here about 20
minutes 30 minutes early
and had my PS5 set up had everything
loaded up ready to go I was like okay
you know what I should probably
open up obs
just to uh
make sure everything's good
and everything looked good it popped up
on screen just right but then the Audio
I didn't have audio you guys could have
heard audio though
but not me not me
all right so here's what we're gonna do
though right now it's just playing the
music pretty low I want to make sure
that you guys can hear
hear the music very well we'll get we'll
wait till we get in game and check
everything
but yeah sorry we don't have our regular
alerts these are just what I was kind of
the default that I was able to get
enabled very very quickly on very short
notice so guys obviously the secrets out
I've been playing Hogwarts Legacy for
a number of days now
been playing for a number of days now
and I know we promised everybody a
a countdown stream
at the time I didn't I didn't know that
we were going to have this opportunity
and then I also didn't know we would be
able to stream the game so if you've
seen like wizard PhD and James I think
James is still streaming right now too
what they've done today is they've just
kind of streamed non-story stuff because
I mean there's no point in me not
streaming the game right if you guys
don't want to see anything at all I
appreciate you stopping by saying hello
showing your support
but if you don't want to see anything at
all and you can you know hang out here
for the beginning there's Mrs record
tour's name let's go
[Music]
um oh yeah I should probably tweet that
I'm going live too oh my goodness see
I'm just like I'm totally thrown off now
but I'm glad I figured this out tonight
because this week is jam packed with
streams
I don't know if you all and if you
whether you prefer Discord or Twitter or
if you just prefer hanging out right
here on YouTube we've got live streams
planned all week
sorry I just saw that wait now we got
Dumbledore over here okay wait so maybe
members are broken but Subs okay all
right hey I'll take it I'll take it
I'll take it welcome to all the new
subscribers I saw Dustin with a oh my
goodness see this is what this is the
another thing that's broken guys I'm
gonna have a really hard time keeping up
with the alerts all right let's scroll
up
I saw Dustin donated Dustin with five
gifteds by the way welcome to all the
new members of house rack and tour guys
welcome welcome
and then we had Elwyn donated to say Mrs
raconteur was gifted a membership by
elwin the real life new this is the
great that is pretty awesome not gonna
lie
not gonna lie Mrs raconteur has lots of
love for oh that one worked that one
works too okay well
making progress making progress
professional streamer here guys
professional streamer
whew all right and Ellen actually
dropped some news in our Discord shortly
before we went live uh PC players
PC players
Chandler wood Avalanche they've heard
you preloading is now available on Steam
so start your downloads guys start your
downloads to get ready for the game
and welcome in welcome in apologies to
everyone for the late start and I'm
gonna try my best with the alerts here
man it's like the
the subs are showing up in my little
mini feed
but nothing else is
all the memberships all the super chats
okay let me try you know what let me try
this because I had to completely just
completely on the Fly we had to
completely switch to a new program
had a completely call an audible tonight
go to streamlabs OBS instead alright so
let's see I want to make sure okay
Dustin gifted all right we got Dustin
all the new members guys thank you so
much I can't tell if you're gifted or if
you are becoming a member on your own
but either way
thank you very much this is going to be
a fun stream guys it's gonna be a fun
stream we'll kind of explain what I'm
gonna be doing through the game here in
a little bit but
um right here at the beginning no matter
if you don't want to see anything I mean
I guess if you don't want to see the
menu you're kind of too late but
um the little the attire that you see my
character wearing right now that was my
kids my eight-year-old my four-year-old
they are watching me play I was like all
right how about you guys they love they
love customization they're really big
into the Lego games and in the Lego
games you can just you can customize so
much
and they love building their own
characters they love creating their own
characters
and when I told them I was like yeah in
Hogwarts Legacy you can you know you can
customize what you look like
customize your guy you know
so I had to show them I had to show them
how to do it and then they are just
they're just they're just going crazy so
that's what they picked my my youngest
is a huge fan of all things green
Green's favorite color so that's why we
got the green scarf I'm not a Slytherin
I didn't switch on you gryffindors don't
worry and I didn't go dark arts either
my kids man they just they like the bad
guy look what can I say they like the
bad guy look so they picked that we got
the green rocking the green scarf and
you can't really tell but the gloves are
green as well right there
and then the dark arts that's actually
not the dark arts um like shirt and
pants it just goes really well with it
and then it is the dark arts hat the
dark arts uh cloak
and then the um I can't remember the
name of the Mask right there whoa wait a
second
wait wait did we just have a 99 dollar
basically a 100 donation what
Andrew are you kidding me dude loved
watching you this last year brother I'm
so excited for this release and all the
growth your channel has had
congratulations my goodness Andrew
man
thank you so much first of all
uh this this past I mean the past two
and a half years really it's been insane
it's been insane and then to get this
opportunity to
you know be able to play the game early
well go out I mean we did the the
preview event a few weeks ago that alone
was incredible
and then after that to be able to get
the game early and start playing it so
we had that review ready well it's
really not even a review because I
haven't even beaten the game I'm about
20 hours in from what I understand
there's still a lot more I don't even
think I'm halfway
don't think I'm halfway
I um the last thing again I'm not gonna
spoil anything story wise but like stuff
you guys already know about I just got
rumor requirement just got it like a few
hours ago in my playthrough still no
beasts nope no Fantastic Beasts like
I've seen them in the world but I
haven't been able to oh my dual shot
disconnected
but but that's it so Andrew thank you so
much for being here and thank you for
that incredible incredible donation
followed up by Let's see we had a
wedding with a donation as well are you
going to do an episodic walkthrough on
YouTube like a Let's Play episode one
two Etc or just long streams
I think I might oh man so people been
asking me this question for years
literal literal okay maybe not literally
years but I feel like since within the
past year for sure we've been getting
that question a lot
I think I might have to do both
I mean so for sure obviously we're gonna
be streaming it
um these first couple streams on Twitch
YouTube whatever it may be it's just
gonna be me finishing my playthrough
Tonight on YouTube the plan
because I promise you guys like a
countdown stream
we're not going to do story stuff we're
just not going to do story stuff tonight
so for the people who do want to hang
out kind of just you guys are free to
ask questions about the game I'll answer
them to the best of my ability if it's
something I don't think you should know
yet then I will I'll skirt around it and
say I don't really want to say I think
you should figure that out on your own
uh but yeah tonight we're just gonna be
exploring the open world maybe doing
like some of the little uh not like
Merlin puzzles or anything because I
think those are fun to solve on your own
but yeah we'll just kind of see what we
get into in the open world I got some I
got some plans we can look around
Hogwarts too I just don't want to spoil
like anything major story-wise oh oh
another thing I want to show people is
the um
like screenshots
capturing screenshots they do not have a
photo mode but uh episodic whatever I do
when they will be posted here on YouTube
as well so we're gonna do some twitch
we're gonna do some YouTube I'm gonna do
multiple playthroughs probably like evil
playthroughs my first playthrough is
good Gryffindor so we'll just have to
see but thanks so much for the Super
Chat and then
[Music]
what it what is going on
Dylan
with a 100 donation
off the heels of the two other donations
and I think Dustin had one in there as
well I need to I'm gonna have to find
Dustin's
I know Dustin for sure had the gift of
memberships uh but Dylan my goodness
dude so happy for the entire Journey
that we have spent to reach this point
Thank You retro for all the content
smash that like button Dylan thank you
so much dude guys Dylan is also a
moderator both here on the YouTube and
in our Discord
um just an all-around cool guy not not
just because he donates all the time
but because he's just a good dude man
and I love having him in the community
same for Elwyn same for Andrew who just
donated as well I mean my goodness what
a way to start the Stream
what a way to start the stream guys Oh
My My Controller disconnected oh but see
what I love about this like this little
interactive scene I guess it only
happens at the beginning but when you
first get into this little loading
screen here sometimes there are like
interactive elements that
happen in the background
but I guess they I guess they stop after
a bit
and then they're gonna have like this
little message of the day right here
this is cool looks like no patch yet I
did check right before I hopped on
but guys I just I cannot get over these
donations man I cannot get over this
incredible all right let's make sure I
didn't miss anything else I know we had
a bunch of new subscribers we had a
bunch of new uh members through the
gifted okay there's Dustin's five gifted
I'm scrolling now Nico with the six
months
I can't believe it's only how has it
only been six months
of course Nico's been following since
our OG twitch days what a journey it has
been I hope you all have a fun time
defining your legacies indeed Nico
it's it's crazy man it really is crazy
that it's finally here
but Nico thank you for the six months
and all the support everything you do
over the years
everything you do over the years
uh and then there's Dustin's five dollar
donation stopping by at the start saw
where mobile finally got a gifted sell
button did they really
that's awesome I'm so far behind Dustin
so I hope you're still here my apologies
if you're watching this in the replay
and you see it then there you go
but yeah guys it was just uh our OBS
decided to
die tonight before we got started
lost a lot of my settings
all right now let's get caught up here
so there we had we had weddings donation
I just want to make sure I don't miss
any of the donations and then I'm gonna
get caught up on chat here
so there's Alex or Andrew and then
Dylan's and then
Let's see we also had caked will you
please show us the wand customization
hmm
you know what here's what I want to do
anything that is like spoilery tonight
spoilery
here's what we're gonna do we're gonna
put it up to the chat
we are going to put it up to the chat
so
here it is I'm gonna put it in the poll
question right now show wand
and I'm not even saying there's
customization in the game
show one customization on stream and
then you guys get yes or no
we'll let it run for about 10 minutes
if you want to see it
we'll let it run
oh this is gonna be fun this is gonna be
fun I like this
but cake thank you for the donation and
even if I don't show it on stream caked
there will be videos coming for sure for
sure for sure for sure yeah I already
here's what I'm gonna here's what I'm
gonna start out the Stream
wait another
what
what is this legit
okay
I think that's Nico Nico my goodness
okay hold on hold on Stacy politest two
dollar donation thanks for everything
heard 60 hours to finish yeah I've heard
a lot of uh
there was a guy who was with WB in the
UK who I think it said it took him 57
hours to get the Platinum but keep in
mind the platinum's not necessarily
doing every single thing in the game
keep that in mind uh and then I've heard
upwards of 80 80 to 85 hours depending
on doing everything and then we had
Lorena with the five gifteds then we had
Hold On Let's see we had Lorraine with
the five gifteds thank you so much guys
welcome to all the new members and then
we had Nico with another 100 guys
the moderators need to stop seriously
the moderators already do my wife's
telling me all the time mods Mrs
raconteur was here earlier I don't know
if she's still here or not she's telling
me all the time she's like you've got
you've got to do something for your mods
I'm gonna get get something get their
address get their email I'm sending them
something
you guys do not need to give anything
else mods this the time that you guys
get Nico you of all people have been
here for so long
for people Nico stop it stop it
with the 100 Nico the journey has made
this game for me even before I play it
myself I totally agree dude I totally
agree so there was a comment today on
YouTube it's like this man's been
covering this game for two and a half
years of course he is
I had to laugh I was like
yeah that'd be kind of awkward if it was
like guys
it actually sucks this game we've been
waiting on for two years it's actually
pretty bad it's not good don't buy it
we are a channel we're gonna take a hard
pivot here
hard pivot
yeah big announcement guys Minecraft
streamer full time here we go
big announcement there we go dude oh
Nico also said Retros content has always
been good but it has reached new levels
now well deserve and I look forward to
what's to come Nico seriously man thank
you not only for the donation but for
everything you do guys Nico a pivotal
part of the community does so I mean he
basically created our Discord actually I
take that back my buddy Chris stallion
years ago set up the Discord had a very
good setup for it uh then Chris stallion
I don't know if if I haven't talked
Christine in a while man I miss chatting
with him he had it set up then he moved
and so he was in a different time zone
we didn't get as much time to actually
interact like we did before
um so
Nico came in and it's like because I
told him I was like dude we kind of need
to freshen up the Discord I reached out
to crystalian Nico's like let me you
mind you mind so I take it away built it
tweet I actually tweaked what we had and
so anybody that's in the Discord make
sure you think Nico you have Nico to
thank for it Nico to thank for it
okay
hold on hold on we cannot
I don't even know if I have alerts set
up on this other but I feel like I need
to go full cam for this
I feel like I need to go full cam for
just a moment here actually hold on wait
all right
um we're gonna try it we're gonna try
full cam
My Stream broke before we started
tonight guys it broke all my alerts went
live or went dead
our boy Andrew here
Andrew dude
did you did you put the decimal
did you mean 39.99
because I'll happily give it back dude
if you did if that was a mistake
I will happily give it back dude some of
those streamers be hardcore right
they're like no no refunds done
oh my God Andrew dude chat I want to
make sure everyone
Andrew here with a three a 400 let's
just call it what it is a 400 donation
what
I'll let the mods take a break from the
donations you've earned this brother
Andrew dude
I'm I'm at a loss man I'm I am seriously
at a loss
dude thank you so much I I mean
I I don't know what to say I don't know
what to say
I cannot imagine dropping four hundred
dollars like that dude I I hope
I hope it was the correct amount if not
hit me up on Twitter it's okay you know
we'll figure something out but dude
thank you so much
um
really man I've never seen uh I haven't
either I've never seen some but donate
that much I haven't either
elwyn's wave in the white flag
I just guys we haven't even we hadn't
even gotten started yet
Andrew man like seriously I I don't know
what else to say dude other than thank
you and I hope that that my content has
brought you
brought you some value especially if
you're donating donating like that I
hope you have found something that you
really enjoy obviously I you probably
feel like you're in a good place if
you're gonna drop that but thank you so
much dude it has been um yeah it's been
a wild wild two and a half years a lot
of hard work and I mean I don't wanna
I don't want to like overstate it or
anything but like and some of the people
have been here for a while like Nico
knows man like how many people are in
here right now looks like over 700 if
this number I'm looking at is right
guys I mean like three years ago we were
streaming on Twitch to
if if five people showed up
it I was I was having a good time if 10
showed up oh my gosh I've got presents
and now we now we've got the game that
we have been covering for two and a half
years
and it's just it's incredible dude it's
incredible
Andrew again thank you very much so glad
that that you that you love the content
dude so glad he doesn't have a
membership
can you oh you can't gift you can't give
to specific people on on YouTube can you
I was I was literally gonna go in and
gift it right now I was gonna gonna gift
it right now
to our buddy Andrew
oh my goodness guys I'm so sorry I know
I'm behind on chat that just
completely threw me off if my wife's
still watching she's probably losing her
mind right now
she's probably thinking that was some
some kids like stolen their parents
credit card
holy cow okay
all right all right let me
I haven't even okay hold on Noob I don't
know if you're here Noob I'm gonna pause
I'm gonna pause
we're gonna hydrate
we're gonna hydrate oh hold on I think
my wife is watching
I got a text from her
almost in tears I'm losing my mind
oh Mrs racketour she's still new to all
this guys I mean she knew
she's always believed in me she's always
believed in me but I don't think
I don't think she knew like what all
like how big this could really get
and so when we had that video the other
day hit one million and then it hit 2
million
Mrs raconteur was like oh you like you
got some people watching
you got people watching you now because
you know it's one thing when you tell
people I got a YouTube channel
and they're like oh that's cool like
you know your five subscribers your mom
your dad your grandmother
you posted on Facebook get a couple
friends to give you that courtesy click
like what like what do you mean when you
got a YouTube channel
so yeah it's been a fun ride for her
it's been a really fun ride Andrew I got
my urine bonus I've got another 500 for
you if you show us the one customization
what
holy okay
well Andrew guess what got a chat thank
you chat thank you because our poll with
552 votes
81 want to see the one customization so
ladies and gentlemen
I think it's time
to show the wand customization
you know what I did forget to do oh my
gosh I'm all over the place tonight guys
I'm all over the place Pro streamer here
by the way Pro streamer welcome
twitch.tv uh youtube.com uh we have an
Instagram as well
whoo Okay so
wow wow all right let me let me do this
really quick so I'm gonna go to my link
here I'm gonna share out the link
all right I'm gonna say live now
see man I the stream the the OBS errors
got me all thrown off before we even
started and then you guys just coming in
hot right now
with back I mean do we have trip we had
three 100s Elwyn with a 20 gifted Dustin
with some gifted a few more other
donations
and then Andrew with a four hundred
dollar
[Music]
we are live now with
Hogwarts Legacy
and Counting or uh for a special
launch stream no
story spoilers
oh I should put getting ready to show
off one customization
and let's see we'll throw a little GIF
on there because for whatever reason
links are broken for me right now
and boom all right it's tweeted
tweeted
and we also had let's see uh oof oof
dead became a member welcome thank you
for
joining house rack and tour my friends
guys I haven't I haven't streamed
gameplay in a while this is so weird
hold on I think I need to adjust my
my seat too all right so for anybody who
does not want to see anything at all
anything at all
um I don't know you can put the game you
can put the stream on audio only or
something We're not gonna do any story
stuff I am at level 22 22 so you're
gonna see gameplay elements you're gonna
see like clothing attire stuff like that
but then we're mainly just going to be
exploring the open world
um yeah so I'm a level 22 Gryffindor